لبيك لا شريك لك لبيك واجبات الحج سبعه
اولا الاحرام من الميقات حيث هناك مواقيت
مكانيه يلزم الحاجه الا يتجاوزها دون ان
يحرم منها بحسب الوجهه التي قصد مكه منها
ثانيا الوقوف بعرفه فان وقف نهارا لازمه
البقاء الى غروب الشمس وان وقف ليلا كفاه
ذلك حتى طلوع فجر يوم العيد وذلك على خلاف
بين المذاهب في فتره البقاء
ثالثا المبيت بمزدلفه ليله يوم النحر وهو
على اختلاف بين المذاهب في فتره البقاء
رابعا المبيت في منى في ليالي ايام
التشريق حيث يلزم المتعجله ان يبيت ليلتي
الحادي عشر والثاني عشر من ذي الحجه واما
من بقي متاخرا فيلزمه ان يبيت كذلك ليله
الثالثه عشر
خامسا رمي الجمرات الثلاث الصغرى والوسطى
وجمره العقبه سادسا الحلق او التقصير في
حق الرجال والحلق اولى لفعل النبي الكريم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
وللنساء التقصير فقط سابعا اداء طواف
الوداع فاذا فرغ الحاج من اعمال الحج كلها
لزمه ان يطوف بالبيت طواف الوداع قبل ان
يغادر مكه ويعود الى بلده
ومن ترك شيئا من هذه الواجبات وجب عليه دم
اي ان يذبح لله الا ان يكون له عذر شرعي
وذلك كله على اختلاف في التفاصيل والشروط
بين المذاهب
[موسيقى]